The chronological and geographical structure of Luke acts is thematic and
theological,
not historical.
That's what we talked about last time.
How that you can actually see the author of Luke acts taking sources that he
took him before him,
perhaps some oral sources.
I've argued that some of these were even written sources because it seems like
you can actually see where he takes something that was on a written account of
the spread of Christianity slices.
It at one place separates that and put several,
put several chapters in acts between them,
between them.
We also had very clear from the nine the 10 chapters in the gospel of Luke,
which we call the journey to Jerusalem section,
that this is an artificial construction on the author's part because he he,
he tells us at one point at this point,
Jesus set his face to go to Jerusalem and then he's taken material that he's
found in the gospel of mark in different places.
Some parables.
Here's some stories.
Here are some teachings here.
He's taken other things that he probably found in Q in different places.
Although,
because remember we don't possess an actual written document of queue.
It's a hypothetical document,
but we can we,
we figured that if he did this with mark who's document we do possess and
therefore can see how he changes the order of material he presents from mark.
He probably did the same thing with Q also.
So we can see that he's taken things from different sources that he had and put
them into this 10 long 10 chapter long journey to Jerusalem.
So Luke and acts looks like a historical document and this is what fools people
do you remember back earlier in the beginning of the semester where we compared
the first two chapters of Paul's letter to the Galatians with the way Paul is
presented as being in and out of Jerusalem and how many times you went to
Jerusalem,
what happened in Jerusalem,
what happened to Damascus?
And I ask you to compare those two accounts and some of you thought,
well I believe the ax account because Paul clearly has an ax to grind in
Galatians.
He's clearly trying to make a point of his independence from the Jerusalem
church.
And the book of acts just looks more like a history.
It looks more like a historical account.
Well by now you know that yes,
even though it looks like a historical account,
especially by ancient a historiographical standards,
it's not a historical account in anything like the modern sense.
So one of those important things to realize,
these texts you're reading,
our creative texts,
they're put together for purposes,
not one of them is coming to you without some kind of ax to grind without some
kind of tendency without some kind of theological or ethical or political
statement to make.
I would go further as the,
well,
I just think I'm an honest realist.
Some people might call me a cynic and say that we need to be careful about all
texts we read and not take any texts that we read as not having some kind of
slant,
some kind of interest,
sometimes some kind of ideological a message.
So that's important to read about all techs in my view.
So the last time I made this point by pointing out how that we can see some
seams in Luke's narrative where he ripped apart the source.
He used to splice something between x eight four and annex 1119 now I want you
to look with me at another passage in acts.
We're going to do the same sort of thing with x six and seven so get your bibles
out.
This is the story of Stephen.
We've talked about Steven's several times already.
He's supposedly the first Christian martyr.
He was one of the Greek speaking Hellenistic Jews whose in Jerusalem at the time
after Jesus's death and resurrection,
and he's chosen as one of the 12 deacons to minister to the widows and to do
other kinds of ministerial work.
Probably because the church was made up partly of Aramaic,
Hebrew speaking Jews and partly of Greek speaking Jews.
Steven seems to have been one of those who has chosen to kind of take care of
the Greek speaking Jewish members of this small little community.
Now you have to remember we're talking a very early period in the history of
Christianity.
It's not even Christianity yet.
This is just a bunch of Jews who believe Jesus is the Messiah.
They were shocked and horrified when Jesus was crucified because the Messiah was
not supposed to be crucified.
There was no Jewish expectation to the Messiah would be a suffering Messiah in
the ancient Jewish world.
That's something that followers of Jesus had to invent.
Once they were shocked at the fact that he was actually crucified,
they idea was the Messiah wouldn't be crucified,
wouldn't suffer,
the Messiah,
would bring an army and overthrow the Romans.
So the fact that they believed he was the messiah and then he's executed,
that just came as a huge shock to these early disciples of Jesus and they
basically had to invent a new concept of what the Jewish Messiah was.
These was a very small group of people huddled in Jerusalem.
Maybe some of them were in Galilee,
maybe in Syria,
maybe if you're the places,
but according to acts,
they're all in Jerusalem at this time and this small group of people are trying
to figure out who Jesus was and what's that means for the history of of
Jerusalem.
Stephen is one of these people and he's accused of several things.
Look at six 11 chapter six verse 11 in acts.
They secretly instigated some men.
That is they,
that the Jewish opponents of this Jesus group,
they had,
uh,
been become offended with Steven and his arguments.
They secretly instigated some men to say,
we have heard him speak blasphemous words against Moses and God.
So they're accusing him of blaspheming against Moses and God.
What would this kind of blast mutans Moses and God mean?
What?
We're going to pick up a few details.
Look at 13,
they set up false witnesses who said this man never stopped saying things
against this holy place.
What is this?
Holy Place,
the temple.
Exactly.
This holy place refers to the Jerusalem temple.
So they're accusing him of preaching against the temple and he says,
and the law for we have heard him say that this Jesus of Nazareth,
we'll destroy this place and we'll change the customs that Moses handed onto us.
Now notice the writer here is telling you this,
cs,
these are false accusations.
Are they false accusations?
Was He really preaching against the temple?
Remember Jesus is portrayed in some of the gospels as himself,
having predicted that the temple would be destroyed.
Does that mean that Jesus was preaching against the temple?
And some Christian writers very quickly portrayed Jesus as teaching that his
followers don't have to keep the Jewish law.
I don't think that's actually correct for the historical Jesus as we'll talk
about when we get to the historical Jesus.
But that's clearly a how some early Christian writers are portraying Jesus as
teaching that you,
Chris,
you followers of mine don't have to keep the Jewish law.
That's what they're accusing Steven of doing.
So is this a false accusation or is this just maybe what Stephen actually was
teaching as being a different form of this,
of the message about Jesus?
Notice then we would get to,
these are the accusations about,
uh,
the,
about Steven,
but then in chapter seven,
we get Steven's own speech.
Now,
this is very interesting.
I wish I could read the whole thing because it's rhetorically very powerful.
What Steven does is he starts off just talking about,
um,
the God who appeared to Abraham and Mesopotamia.
He tells the story that any of us Christians would recognize as the story of the
Old Testament God and his interactions with Abraham and Moses and which Jews
would recognize as Rick folk did in Jewish scripture and Jewish tradition.
And that's the way the most part of the first half of that chapter seven goes.
It's a retelling of the Hebrew Bible story about God,
the God of Israel.
What really becomes interesting is though,
when it gets to a around verse 37 in Chapter Seven,
so I mean 35 in chapter seven so look at that with me now,
right before this,
notice this is,
I have surely seen the mistreatment of my people.
This is God talking who are in Egypt and have heard their groaning and I have
come down to rescue them.
Come now I will send you to Egypt.
So God is telling Moses at this point he's going to send him to Egypt to deliver
the people.
And we expect the whole story then of the exodus to come next.
But what does it say in verse 35 it was this Moses whom they rejected when they
said,
who made you ruler and judge and whom God now sent as both ruler and liberated
through the angel who appeared to him in the bush.
In other words,
instead of emphasizing here,
Moses activity of leading the Israelites out of captivity,
he emphasizes another aspect of the story that's there in the Old Testament
story because yes,
one of the Israelites and you know the story is Moses comes upon to Israelites
who are fighting their both their slaves in Egypt this time and he says to one
of the Israelites,
is that any way to treat your brother?
And that is
like rebukes him and says,
who set you up as a judge over us?
Notice that's the verse that Steven's centers on at this point to emphasize the
story about Moses.
Not so much Moses is just deliver,
but Moses as someone rejected by the people.
Have we seen that before?
Uh Huh.
One of the themes of Luke acts is profits get rejected by the people.
So there,
verse 35,
that's what he just has this,
let's just keep reading there.
He led them out having performed wonders and signs in Egypt,
the Red Sea,
and in the wilderness for 40 years.
This is the Moses who said to the Israelites,
God will raise up a prophet for you from your own people as he raised me up.
Now in the Old Testament,
it seems like Moses is talking about anybody know
who follows Moses as the leader of the people of Israel.
Yes,
sir.
Joshua.
Exactly.
So it sounds like Moses predicting Joshua's being raised up,
uh,
after he dies,
but that's not what Stephen thinks.
Yeah.
Uh,
this is the mosaic.
God will raise your private [inaudible].
He is the one who will,
who was in the congregation in the wilderness with the angel who spoke to him at
Mount Sinai with our ancestors.
He received living oracles to give to us.
Our ancestors were unwilling to obey him.
Instead,
they pushed him aside in their hearts and turned back to Egypt.
And then it tells about,
uh,
the,
the golden calf story,
how the Israelites rejected Moses and the law and made a golden calf toric.
Now look at seven 44,
our ancestors had the tent of testimony in the Wilderness as God directly when
he spoke to Moses,
ordering him to make it according to the pattern he had seen.
This refers to the stories and excess about the tabernacle,
the tent of testimony.
Um,
this is a big tent that's taught the construction,
which has talked about this is where God would meet the people,
Israel and Moses before the building of the temple.
So Steven is fine with us.
He's saying God constructed Moses and Moses directed the people to construct
this tent of witness or meeting of,
of God with Israel.
And that's where God chose to be with his people according to the Bible.
So he's that he gives that little history,
but then look at 45,
our ancestors in turn brought it in with just some Joshua when they dispossessed
the nations that God drove out before our ancestors.
And it was there until the time of David.
So up until the time of David,
the people of Israel had a tabernacle that where they met God,
who found favor with God and asked what he might,
that he might find a dwelling place for the House of Jacob.
So David was the first one who raised the idea of having a temple to God,
not just the Tabernacle but the temple.
That's where we're going in the history here.
But it was Solomon who built the house for him.
Yet the most high God does not dwell in health is made with human hands.
Where does the story go?
The store has gone fine up to this point.
It's just like we see it in exodus and the Old Testament,
the Hebrew Bible,
Solomon.
David wanted to build a temple for God.
God said,
no.
Solomon comes up later and he wants to build a temple and finally God says yes,
at least according to part of the Hebrew Bible,
but another part of the Hebrew Bible always had a little bit of a prejudice
against the idea that anybody could build a house for God.
Some profits seemed not to like the temple.
So much.
Other profits seem to like the temple.
So much what Steven is doing,
he's pulling out of the Hebrew Bible,
that kind of anti temple prophetic strain and he's emphasizing that as part of
his message.
Then notice what he quotes there and uh,
patches from the Hebrew Bible.
And then in verse 51 you stiff neck people uncircumcised of heart and ears.
You are forever opposing the Holy Spirit,
just as your ancestors used to do.
What happened to Steven?
He just went,
he,
all of a sudden his panties are really in a wad for no obvious reason.
He's been telling them the story of the building of the temple.
He's been going along fine now he starts and he's gone from preaching now too.
Insulting his audience.
He's insulting the Jews and Jerusalem.
He's accusing them of being on the wrong side of history.
Why?
Because they wanted to build a temple.
Which of the prophets did your ancestors not persecute?
They killed those who,
who foretold the coming of the righteous one and now you have it become his
betrayers and murderers.
You are the ones who receive the law as our Dang bite angels.
What
angels gave the Jewish law?
I thought God gave the law the Torah on Sinai.
I thought God wrote this,
the stones with his finger and gave them to Moses and Moses carried him down the
mountain.
Well,
yeah,
that's what scripture says,
but by this time and Jewish history,
it was not uncommon for Jews,
even pious Jews to believe that God did not himself directly right the law and
give it to Moses angels.
Did most of them believe that this was with God's pleasure.
In principle,
God wanted the angels to deliver the law to the Jews,
but at least they put between God and Moses.
Angels and angels according to some of these traditions were the ones who
actually gave the law to the Israelites and to Moses as we'll come to see.
Paul believed this also,
it wasn't an uncommon view among Jews,
but notice what Steven does.
He actually uses this tradition
that the angels were the ones who gave the law to Moses to distance God a bit
from the law to make the law a little bit less connected to God.
He demotes the by reading the angels in between there.
So notice he's done.
Steven has done two things in this speech.
He's grabbed hold of a certain prophetic tradition that we know is already there
in the Bible,
which criticized the Jerusalem temple.
It's there in some profits.
Why should God need a house?
God doesn't need a house.
God is everywhere.
So Steven pulls on that tradition that's already in the Bible and then he adds
this tradition about that was common at the time about Moses being the ones who
actually gave the law.
I mean the angels being the ones who actually gave the law to Moses rather than
God directly.
And then he turns all this on his Jewish attackers,
his critics,
and that's what he accuses them up and then says,
you crucified Jesus.
Just like the people rejected Moses and all the profits when they heard these
things,
they became enraged and ground their teeth.
At Steven and they stone him.
Is it any surprise they stone him.
Now ask the question again.
When the author of acts sets these things up as false accusations against
Steven,
who's right,
Stephen or the author Stephen actually does look like in his own speech to be
attacking both the law and the temple.
That is this holy place and Moses,
I think what's going on here is another place we see the author of acts taking
material he has before him and sticking it into a place and then riding around
it.
So for example,
the author of acts is the one who says these were false accusations against
Steven.
They set up and they were totally false.
Steven was totally innocent,
but then he actually includes Steven speech,
which backs up the accusations.
The other thing that makes this seem to me clearly that the author is using
prior material is that this,
this view of the temple that Steven presents this view that the temple is not
good,
that God doesn't like the temple and it's only stiff neck and uncircumcised of
heart.
People who want,
who believe in the temple.
That's not the view of the author of acts.
How do you know that?
Because over and over again,
uh,
Luke,
the author of acts actually portrays the disciples as meeting in the temple
right after the resurrection of Jesus.
Where does it say they met and had prayers and preached and prayed in the
temple?
The disciples of Jesus meet in the temple.
They're not anti temple.
When Paul goes off around the world and then he comes back to Jerusalem,
what does he do to show his piety?
He takes a vow.
The Nazarite vow.
He shaves his head.
He donates money,
which goes to the temple for sacrifices,
and he himself goes to the temple to worship.
Paul worships in the temple,
so the author of acts is not himself anti temple.
He believes that the Jerusalem temple is just fine for Jews.
He actually doesn't think gentiles need to pay that much attention to it,
but he believes it's perfectly fine for Jews.
But he includes in here us a speech by Steven that is both anti temple and
somewhat anti law.
This shows that this author is using these different sources.
The speech of Stephen Comes from a pre Lucan source and it set into the book of
acts.
Now that means we can see his editorial activity,
but notice how what it also tells us,
we can see
we actually have then two different forms of early Christianity.
Okay.
Luke represents one and Steven,
even embedded within Luke's on document represents another.
We've got two different ideas.
Is the law of Moses something that's given by angels in that Ford demoted and
up,
therefore not very good in which the law of Moses gets criticized or is the law
of Moses perfectly fine,
the Jewish law with the that that signals their ethnicity as being people of
Israel?
That's the point of view of Luke.
Is the temple something that is good.
That's a sign of of God's covenant with Israel,
which seems to be the view of most of the people in Luke acts or is the temple
something that shows that you're stiff necked if you believe in its efficacy?
That seems to be Steven's view.
In other words,
we have little hints here that even within one book in the New Testament,
we have different kinds of early Christianity represented with slightly
different theologies.
Now we can also see it several other times where,
um,
Luke takes and changes things.
I talked about this at the very last,
my of my session last time,
but I want to just reiterate it very quickly.
So some of you,
if you don't have throt Martins Gospel parallels or some other gospel parallels,
this is why these are very useful cause I'm gonna use this that way.
I have mark right here and Luke right here for the same passage and I can
compare them very,
very directly,
see exactly what words they have differently.
If you don't have that,
put one of your fingers where we talked about last time,
mark 1314 through 27 that's mark 1314 through 27 and put another finger at Luke
2120 through 33 Luke 2120 through 33 and if you have Throckmorton it's paragraph
two 16 section two 16 and Throckmorton.
Okay.
So look at the market passage first
three 14 but when you see the desolating sacrilege set up where it ought not to
be,
let the reader understand.
And then he says,
get out of town.
Go Get out of Judea,
go to the mountains because it's all all hell's breaking loose anytime.
And then he gives several things.
They're there.
And if you look at Luke,
where Luke a parallel on Luke 2120 Luke doesn't say the desolating sacrilege,
he just says when you see Jerusalem surrounded by armies,
then know that its desolation has come near.
See there's a common wording there,
but it's slightly different.
And then Luke also leukocytosis.
Those inside the city should leave those in the country,
should not enter it.
And then you go on th there's,
there's great distress in both places.
Look at verse 21 of Mark 13 if anyone says to you at this time,
look here the Messiah,
or look there,
yes,
do not believe it.
False profits.
Now that's also gonna be in Luke,
been a totally different place that's kinetic contained in Luke chapter 17 so
Luke's using that false prophet material.
But not in this context.
And then look at mark 1324 but in those days,
after that suffering,
the sun will be dark and the moon will not give it's light.
The stars will be falling from heaven.
In other words,
after all this other stuff he's told you,
that's when the big catastrophic catastrophe takes place.
The Sun eclipses the stars fall from heaven,
the Moon's dark.
Luke also has something like that.
And Luke 2125 there will be signs in the sun,
the moon and the stars and on earth distress among nations caused by the roaring
of the seed people.
And so Luke is a slightly different material
and
the problem is Luke,
then
yes,
notice how right after that it set,
mark has the son of man coming with the clouds of glory in verse 26 so right
after that you have the son of man coming down,
but Luke has a bunch of more material and you don't get anything until you see
Luke 2132 grace says this generation will not pass away until all things are
taken place.
Heaven and earth will pass away.
But my words will not pass away.
And then where does,
well,
I must have passed it.
Where is it that uh,
okay,
Luke talks about the time of the gentiles.
Give me the verse.
Cool.
24.
Yes,
that's right.
Um,
in 24,
they will,
there'll be great distress on earth and residents.
They will fall by the edge of the sword and be taken away as captive among all
nations and Jerusalem will be trampled on by the gentiles until the time of the
gentiles had been fulfilled.
So notice Luke in search,
there is something that's not there and the other sources,
which is that Jerusalem will be captured.
It'll be destroyed.
Uh,
j,
uh,
there will have a time of the gentiles in between.
And then Luke goes on to talk about the coming of Jesus and the,
the very end again,
one of these places where you can clearly see the editorial seams of the rider
and you have the time of the gentiles.
So one,
one of the things that we've seen is that Luke is carefully constructing his
sources to make his own point.
What I want to do now is now turn attention to,
okay,
what are some of those points?
What are some of the points we've already talked about?
What are some ones?
Luke's basic messages.
One,
Jesus is like the prophets.
Jesus is like Elijah and Elisha to profits get rejected by their people.
Three when you're rejected by the people,
then the message goes out to other corners of the earth.
And then this schematic view of history that we talked about later from
[inaudible],
from Jerusalem to Judea to area to the ends of the earth.
Now let's look at how some of these pleadings play out.
One of Luke's most important messages is to the Jew.
First,
let's look at Luke one five through seven we're going to spend a little time in
Luke.
Now,
the beginning parts of Luke.
Luke is very concerned to show,
as I said last time,
the John Jesus is a good Jewish boy.
His parents are good Jewish parents.
He comes from good Jewish extended family.
So Luke five this is right after the very beginning of the prologue,
which I mentioned last week.
I talked about last time.
In the days of King Herod of Judea.
There was a priest named Zechariah who belonged to the priestly order of Abajo.
His wife was a descendant of Aaron.
Her name was Elizabeth.
Both of them were righteous before God living blamelessly according to all the
commandments and regulations of the Lord,
but they had no children because Elizabeth was barren and both were getting on
in years.
Doesn't that sound kind of familiar?
Old,
very righteous couple can't have children she's getting on in years.
She's barren.
Abraham and Sarah sounds like lots of people.
It sounds like Abraham and Sarah.
It also is going to sound like Hannah,
the mother of Samuel,
but there are,
these are these wonderful stories in the Bible about,
you know,
this old couple who want to have children and can't have children.
So this is already evoking this idea of Jesus's family being like a story.
They're a family that you might find them right there in scripture.
They're just like that.
Look at one 25
uh,
this is when Elizabeth can see for five months she made seclusion.
You said,
this is what the Lord has done for me.
When he looked favorably on on me and took away the disgrace I've endured among
my people.
Sounds like it's right out of first Samuel second chapter.
Look,
keep one finger right there.
In fact,
first read chapter one 46 oh wait,
this is the magnificant.
Yeah.
Look at chapter one 46 Mary said,
my soul magnifies the Lord.
My spirit rejoices in God my savior,
for he has looked with favor on the lowliness of his servant.
Surely from now on,
all generations will call me blessing.
I read this last time.
There's a lot of messages about the rich will be sent into away.
The poor will be raised up the reversal of status in the world.
Now keep your finger there and go all the way to the Old Testament.
The Hebrew Bible to first Samuel.
It's right before the two books called kings,
and right after the book called Ruth,
First Samuel tells about the birth of the Prophet Samuel,
his mother's Hannah.
And here's her story.
In chapter two of first Samuel,
Hannah prayed and said,
my heart exults in the Lord.
My strength is exalted in my God mice mouth.
Derides my enemies because I rejoice in my victory.
There is no holy one like the Lord,
no one besides you.
There's no rock like our God talk no more so proudly.
Let not arrogance come from your mouth.
For the Lord is a god of knowledge and by him actions are weighed.
The bows of the mighty are broken,
but the feeble gird on strength,
and it's a whole song.
You can read the whole thing there,
but if you just keep one finger at first Samuel two and one finger at Luke one
46 Mary's song is obviously fashioned on the song of Hannah.
Yeah,
and the message is the reversal of status of rich and poor.
We can powerful.
That's not all.
Look at chapter one verse 14
yeah,
this is talking about the birth of John The baptist.
His father's the priest Zachariah,
his mother's Elizabeth,
and this is the prophecy that comes with the angel to Zachariah.
You will have joy and gladness and many will rejoice in his birth for he will be
great in the sight of the Lord.
He must never drink wine or strong drink even before his birth.
Who will be filled with the Holy Spirit,
blah,
blah.
John the Baptist is portrayed like Elijah.
Read stories about Elijah.
Similar things you said about him.
Look at two 36 we're going to move quickly.
There was a prophet Anna,
the daughter of Fenway,
of the tribe of Asher.
You hear how biblical that sounds.
That's real biblical.
The guy who wrote this,
I don't think he was a Jew.
I think there's probably a gentile,
but he spoke Greek as his main language,
so it's not like he's,
he's just,
you know,
automatically talking this way.
In a sense,
I think he's consciously constructing his book to sound like the Bible,
to sound like the Jewish scripture.
She was a great age,
having lived with her husband's seven years after our marriage than as a widow
to the age of 84 she never left the temple.
There's a temple,
but worshiped there with fasting and prayer night and day.
At that moment she came to,
began to praise God to speak about the child.
That's Jesus to all.
You're looking for redemption of Israel.
So Anna is this holy woman.
Just like many of the holy woman in the Bible and then you have these songs and
prayers.
I've already talked about magnificant that Mary says,
look also at one 68 chapter one 68.
Okay.
This is the prayer that semi,
uh,
Zachariah,
the father of John the Baptist praise blessed be the Lord God of Israel for he
has looked favorably on his people and redeemed them.
He raised up a mighty savior for us in the house of separate David.
In other words,
he goes on to quote basically what sounds like a song.
It's very much a song like piece of literary poetry there.
Mary had her Magnificat,
which sounds like scripture.
Zachariah has his benedictus.
Again,
these are the songs that if you're a Roman Catholic or if you're an episcopalian
or dilute urine,
say the magnificant and the Benedictus and these things in liturgy.
Any Lutherans in here?
No.
Any other denominations in here to say these things?
I'm not sure I know which ones actually say the magnificant caught my soul
magnifies the lord of the Benedictus.
But if you're Roman Catholic or Episcopalian,
you say these songs as part of the liturgy,
they come from the New Testament,
but they sound very much like the Old Testament.
So Zachariah has one,
we call it,
they'd been a Dick twos because in Latin,
if you had a Latin Bible in front of you,
the first word of that psalm would be benedict twos molested my soul.
Um,
yeah bless.
It'd be the Lord God of Israel.
The other song is to 19,
which Simeon praise Simeon's is holy man living in the temple again.
There's that theme of the temple when he sees Jesus the baby,
he says,
master,
now let.
Now you are dismissing your servant in peace according to your word,
for my eyes,
have seen your salvation,
which you have prepared in the presence of all peoples.
A light for revelation to the gentiles.
Already at the very beginning of the Gospel,
though Jesus himself won't go to the gentiles during his life.
This is something that Luke will wait until acts to show us.
Simeon predicts it.
He prophesies about it in this little song.
This is called the nuke deputies in critic Christian literature,
surgical tradition,
because in Latin now departs your servant.
That's what the Latin means.
Then there's the piety of the holy family already mentioned before.
Only Luke tells us about the circumcision of Jesus.
Chapter two Verse 21 only Luke tells us in two 22 this is where they're looking
at,
that after the prescribed period,
according to the law of Moses,
see,
Jesus's family followed the law of Moses very well.
They brought him up to Jerusalem to present him to the Lord.
As it is written in the law of the Lord,
every firstborn male shall be designated as holy to the Lord.
They offered a sacrifice according to what is stated in the law of the Lord,
a pair of turtle doves,
and two young pigeons.
In other words,
over and over again,
I could cite several different as an examples.
Luke wants to portray the holy family,
John the Baptist family and the holy family of Jesus and Jesus himself as all
being good Jews who honor the temple,
who keep the law.
They do everything like they're supposed to do.
And so it's no surprise that when you get to the book of acts,
the theme that comes out more than anything is to the Jew first.
So look at acts.
Yeah,
I'm not gonna read all this,
but acts 1346.
This is Paul
and Barnabas.
They'd been speaking on the Sabbath Day,
uh,
to uh,
sit the a synagogue and the people,
some of them believe in some get jealous and verse chapter 13,
verse 46 then both Paul and Barnabas spoke out boldly saying it was necessary
that the word of God should be spoken first to you.
That is to the Jews.
Since you reject it and judge yourselves to be unworthy of eternal life,
we are now turning to the gentiles.
It happens again.
The same thing is said in acts eight chapter 18 verse six.
The same thing is said in chapter 26,
verse 20
over and over again.
See,
Paul goes for it.
He goes to a town,
he goes first to the synagogue.
He preaches in the synagogue.
The Jews reject him.
He's kind of shakes the dust off his feet.
You Jews rejected the Gospel,
therefore we're going to the gentiles.
But he never gets to a point where he finally and completely turns away from the
Jews.
He keeps going back to the Jews and every town he gets too.
But this idea that the message must be preached first to the Jews and only then
to the gentiles is a point that acts makes over and over and over again.
So is it any surprise that in the gospel of Luke,
he wanted it to be so careful to set up Jesus as a good Jew?
That's the beginning of it.
It's only later that it will go to the gentiles.
So that pattern gets played out over and over again until the very end of x.
Now look at the end of acts chapter 28 of acts,
verse 28
okay,
this is at the end of Paul's last speech and acts.
He was in Jerusalem.
He was actually trying to go worship in the temple,
but some of the bad Jews who didn't like Paul,
thought he was trying to take gen piles into the temple,
which would have been against the law.
So they grab him our big riot in suse and they take Paul before the Sanhedrin
that the big sort of Jerusalem kind of Senate type body and they put him on
trial.
Paul's message and all these things is that I didn't do anything wrong.
I'm just here to obey the law.
I'm here to serve the my people,
to honor the traditions of my people and my,
my ethnic,
my ethnic group,
the Jews.
And then eventually though such a big dispute arises him that Paul is arrested
by the Roman governor in order.
He says to protect Paul from being lynched.
Paul is in prison.
Then uh,
finally Paul is afraid he's going to lose a trial with these,
his Jewish enemies on one side.
So he appeals to the Roman governor,
straight to the emperor.
He says,
I'm a Roman citizen.
I appealed the emperor.
So that means he has to go to Rome.
They have to take him to Rome for trial.
So the last part,
Chapter 28 is Paul in Rome.
He preaches again there you have the kind of things happen.
He rents a hall where he,
he again conducts classes and conduct sermons and that sort of thing.
And then this last sermon that he's given to the Jewish leaders in the Jewish
elders,
and notice how it turns out,
he says,
let it be known to you then that the salvation of God has been sent to the
gentiles.
They will listen.
He lived there two whole years of his own expense.
He welcomed all who came to him proclaiming the Kingdom of God and teaching
about the Lord Jesus Christ with all boldness and without hindrance.
In other words,
the very end of the two volume work ends with this message that the message was
preached to the Jews.
They rejected it.
So Paul and the others went to the gentiles and it ends up in Rome,
the capital of the whole world,
which represents the idea that the gospel has now proceeded to the whole world.
Isn't it funny that this author doesn't tell us what happened to Paul?
Does he mind know how Paul supposedly died?
Anybody know?
Yes sir.
He was decapitated,
not accidentally.
It was a Roman sword that did it.
According to Christian tradition,
Jesus Paul was martyred by being beheaded because he was a Roman soldier.
Again,
according to the tradition,
Paul actually never tells us he was a Roman citizen.
He never tells us that it was a Roman citizen,
but according tradition,
he was in fact,
an ax claims that he was a Roman citizen.
So according to that tradition,
you can't crucify a Roman citizen.
So the tradition was that Paul was martyred,
but unlike Peter who was crucified upside down,
according to tradition,
Paul was beheaded in Rome probably sometime in the 60s.
That's the tradition.
Why doesn't Luke tell us that story?
Wouldn't that be the more logical end of the story?
He's told us about Paul's ministry?
He told her about Paul's call.
He's taught us Paul becoming an apostle.
He's told about Paul,
uh,
different missionary journeys.
And he ends up with Paul living in rented rooms in Rome.
I don't think this author wanted us to tell us about how the story ended,
if it actually ended with Paul being martyred in Rome,
because that kind of would spoil the story,
wouldn't it?
Although you kind of could get the hint that since all profits and all
messenger,
the Gospel according to this author are martyred and rejected,
then maybe he could've portrayed Paul as a martyr and told about his death after
all the cause.
And that's a nice little segue into the next major theme of Luke Acts.
And I'm going to talk about profits as martyrs.
Profits in Luke acts get martyred.
Jesus was one of them.
So notice first John the baptist.
John,
I'm not going to read this because we're running a little bit out of time.
John the Baptist himself gets martyred.
Jesus also is a profit marker.
Look at act,
uh,
Luke nine 31.
Now unfortunately going to be going back and forth from Luke to ax.
So you might want to keep fingers in both places.
This is very important.
Point nine 31 of Luke,
okay,
this is the transfiguration story.
You know how it goes.
Jesus.
Take some of his disciples,
Peter,
John,
and James up onto a mountain,
and while they're up there,
this is on their way to Jerusalem.
Clouds overcome it's,
you know,
thunder and lightening.
Imagine Cecil B de Mille Hollywood type lighting effects,
and Jesus appears there with Moses and Elijah flaming just just,
they're all,
they're shining.
And Peter says something.
There's a voice from heaven,
all that sort of thing.
But notice most of the gospels don't tell us what p,
what Jesus and Moses and Elijah were talking about up on the mountain.
Luke tells us
31 they appeared in glory and we're speaking of his departure,
which was about to be accomplished at Jerusalem.
Now the Greek word there for departure is exodus.
Yep.
That word,
the very word of the second book of the Bible in Greek.
They're talking to Jesus about his exodus.
If you read that in Greek,
that would immediately say,
oh,
I,
now I know why Moses is there talking to them.
He needs some advice on how to do an exodus.
And the exodus doesn't refer to just his leaving the country.
He refers to his martyrdom.
And also Jesus also will be portrayed as the profit to the Jews first.
I've already talked about Steven being a prophet and a martyr.
The end of acts with Paul in Rome.
Again,
I just read it to you.
Paul ends up as a prophet to the Jews.
He is the innocent martyr.
Uh,
he's proclaimed innocent over and over again several times.
As a matter of fact,
um,
Paul will be proclaimed first.
Jesus is proclaimed as innocent people that the different realtors will say,
you know,
this guy's innocent.
He's innocent.
What are you doing?
What are you getting upset about?
And over,
and again,
Paul himself will be taken to governors,
Roman governors,
and they'll say,
you know,
well,
I would have released him,
but now he's appealed to Rome.
So we've got to send him to Rome when it gets to Rome.
Even the Jewish elders in Rome who first set and they'd say,
now we've heard rumors,
Paul,
that about you.
We've heard some bad stuff about you,
but we don't have any good evidence.
You're innocent as far as we're concerned.
Even the Jewish leaders in Rome declare Paul innocent.
So over and over again,
people in the book of acts and,
and Luke,
um,
are portrayed as innocent martyrs and profits.
Notice how we see they're all these different diversities of Christianity.
No,
just some basic themes.
But if you take what do these different Christian groups about the Jewish law,
what did Moses believed about the Jewish law?
Anybody remember?
What was Moses stance on what people should do with the Jewish law?
You know,
just remember back a week or so.
What did I say,
Moses?
I mean,
Matthew,
I'm sorry.
I'm crazy.
What was Matthew's view of the,
of the mosaic law?
What did Matthew believe about the mosaic law?
All followers of Jesus should obey it.
It's just there.
Matthew does never get rid of the Jewish law.
He never has Jesus get rid of the Jewish law.
What does mark say about the Jewish law?
Well,
Jesus declared all foods clean.
So Jesus modifies the Jewish law in a substantial way for mark.
What does Luke believe about the Jewish law?
And this is an interesting point.
Luke believes that the Jewish law is the ethnic contract,
if you will,
the ethnic traditions of the Jews.
It's,
it came from God.
It came from Moses and Jews.
Keep it so throughout acts,
if you notice,
the Jewish followers of Jesus continued to keep the law.
Even Paul,
the gentile followers of Jesus aren't required to keep the law.
It's it's as if,
and and people need to wear a nudist.
Americans have their law,
Canadians have their law.
Britain's have their law,
the French have their law,
sort of
every nation and ethnic group has its own laws,
right?
This is the way Lucas thinking about the Jewish law.
He says,
of course it's good.
It's good for Jews.
So should Jews avoid pork?
Yeah,
they're Jews should use be circumcised.
they're Jews.
Even if they're followers of Jesus,
they still keep the Jewish law
gentiles totally.
Or the story.
Why should they not keep the law of Moses?
They're not Jews.
So Luke's,
the view of,
of the law of Moses that you get in Luke and acts is that the law is good ethnic
law and custom for the Jewish people and it's perfectly fine for them to obey it
and to keep it.
It's just not binding on the gentile followers of Jesus.
They will have other ethical things to follow and he gives you some of those
things and chapter 15 so that's,
that's actually very different from what we've seen in Matthew or even in mark,
right?
Luke has a different view of the law.
These are diversity's of Christianity.
We see they weren't all this,
they weren't all in agreement about this.
They probably didn't even know what the others thought.
They may have been living in different geographical areas and just develop their
own different views about what should,
what is the Jewish law and how should it affect the followers of Jesus.
When we get to Paul,
it'll be another story
because it may surprise you.
Paul will believe Luke seems to believe that he doesn't really come out and say
it.
If there's a gentile who sort of wants to keep kosher or wants to get
circumcised,
well,
it's no big deal that he has.
Paul circumcised.
Timothy is follower.
Uh,
at one point Timothy wasn't circumcised.
They're going to be going through some Jewish areas.
So Paul says,
yeah,
let's circumcise Timothy.
Well,
the Paul of his letters doesn't like that at all.
He basically says,
if you're a follower of Jesus and a gentile,
you cannot keep the Jewish law,
otherwise you will fall from grace
trying to keep the law.
The law of Moses,
if you're a gentile disciple of Jesus,
is anathema for Paul and that'll get him in big trouble with both Jews and
Jewish Christians,
Jewish followers of Jesus.
So what the point I'm making is that when we get to Paula,
we'll see another different kind of view of the law.
So it all shows that these people were trying to figure out what does it mean to
follow a Jewish Messiah if you're not Jewish,
what does it mean that we're following a messiah who was predicted by Moses in
the law and yet we're not keeping the law.
In fact,
they'd say,
what does it mean to have a messiah at all?
What does Messiah mean?
And here's the last little difference.
I'll say in the next two or three minutes because we'll come back to this also.
We've already seen different Christologies one of those two bit words again,
what does Christology mean?
Anybody?
Chris Allergy,
whether you believe Jesus was human or divine,
very good.
It means any doctrine of Jesus.
It could be whether is human to divine,
it could be whether he's,
you know,
uh,
fish.
Any teaching about Jesus is a Christology.
It's what is your theology of Jesus Christ.
That's Christology.
And we've already seen different ones.
For example,
I've already said mark.
Um,
Luke mark believes that Jesus,
his death was a ransom.
Jesus died for your sins.
His death was sort of like a sacrifice say.
But at one point in mark 10 45,
Jesus says to his disciples,
the son of man came to give his life as a ransom for many.
In other words,
Jesus,
his death is for you to buy you up to save you.
That's picked up in Matthew 2028 do you know what that saying is?
Never found in Luke.
In fact,
you can find nothing in the gospel of Luke,
which identifies the death of Jesus as being an atonement for sins of people.
Luke does not take Jesus' death as being a ransom in the way that Mark Matthew
do.
Why Jesus,
his death is important for Luke,
right?
But again,
what is the meaning of Jesus's death in Luke a profit martyr.
He's the innocent prophet who is more martyred for his prophecy.
That's the meaning of the death of Jesus in Luke and acts,
so we have very different christologies about the meaning of the death of Jesus
already in these different gospels.
All of this is just to say,
we're going to find this again.
We can find it in John.
We're going to find it in other places early.
These early Christian texts,
if you read them really,
really carefully,
not quickly,
carefully,
you'll see amazing ways that it opens up toll windows into the very earliest
period of Christianity that most modern people have no idea existed.
The idea that there could be Christians who didn't believe Jesus,
his life was an atonement.
The idea that there were Christians who believed every Christian should keep the
Jewish law.
The idea.
We've also seen that there could have been Christians who believed that the god
who created the world was evil.
These were all there.
We'll talk about another form of it next week.
See you next week.